Quatre des chaudières ne sont toujours pas allumées.
Non, je n'en vois pas le besoin.
Nous faisons une moyenne très honorable.
Le voyage inaugural du Titanic doit faire les gros titres.
Oh ben, faut faire gaffe quand même, hein.
Monsieur, je préférerais ne pas pousser les moteurs tant qu'ils ne sont pas rôdés
Ouais voilà,  parce qu'en plus moi j'ai payé pour une semaine
donc j'aime autant que ça dure une semaine quoi, pour la bouffe et tout.
Mais quelle glorieuse fin de carrière pour vous que ce voyage si nous arrivions
à New York mardi soir à la surprise générale
on ferait la une des journaux du matin
Mais non, c'est bien, il a dit c'est bien comme ça, parce que après
c'est un coup à se manger un iceberg et tout donc..
Non,  mais ça serait chiant quand même.
Finir sur un exploit mon cher Edouard.
Brave homme.
Mais il est guéri !
Comment tu te sens ?
Bah je ne crois pas que ça risque de t'arriver.
Tu n'as pas à t'inquiéter pour ça.
La première chose que je ferai quand je serai rentré chez moi,
ce sera de manger quelque chose de bon.
Ouais, mais sinon vous voulez pas qu'on le mette en quarantaine...
...Juste pour être sûr.
Je ne tiens pas du tout à savoir avec quoi c'est fait.
Je me contente d'avaler.
Ben qu'est ce qui se passe mon vieux ?
C'est dégueulasse mais pas à ce point là.
Oui... Ou alors, ça a un rapport avec l'extra-terrestre justement
Qu'est ce que t'as Kane ?
-L'extra-terrestre de la dernière fois
Ça a l'air sérieux.
Ouvre lui la bouche.
Mets lui ça dans la bouche.
-Là, si vous faites bien gaffe
on entend clairement les bruits d'extra-terrestre
-Là, juste là
Ok.
- Ne le touche pas, ne le touche pas !
-Eh bah si, si touche le même, tue le même !
-Parce que là, il va se barrer et là on va être dans la mer...
-Bon, eh bien moi si vous me cherchez je suis dans ma chambre
enfermé jusqu'à la fin des temps.
-Bonne chance avec le...
Abritez-vous sous le pont
Abritez-vous sous le pont !
Courez à l'abri, vite ! à l'abri
Hank est là-bas, je vais le chercher !
Non ! non !
Emmène ta mère à l'abri
Ben, non ! Parce que c'est Superman en fait
Donc lui il peut voler, il peut soulever des maisons et tout
En fait c'est plus à lui d'y aller parce qu'il a l'air plus en forme que...
monsieur
Hank !
Parce que Hank c'est le chien en plus?
C'est même pas un humain?
Bon vas-y on s'en fout , va sauver ton père là.
Vas-y là , vas-y, même sans être Superman il y a le temps là !
Bon, t'es chiant, j'y vais
Bon, moi j'ai plus le temps d'y aller, par contre toi, vu que tu es Superman, tu y vas
hyper vite tu reviens, personne voit rien t'as le temps de le sauver là.
Là t'as le temps
...là t'as le temps
là c'est compliqué
là c'est très chaud
et.. là c'est mort
Ouais là il est mort là !
A priori, pris dans une tornade comme ça...
les stats pfff... sont nulles
il est mort
Messieurs, bienvenue au Fight Club.
La première règle du Fight Club est :
il est interdit de parler du Fight Club.
La seconde règle du Fight Club est :
Excusez-moi, vous avez dit 2 fois la même chose non ?
Troisième règle du Fight Club :
quelqu'un crie stop,
quelqu'un s'écroule ou n'en peut plus
le combat est terminé.
Il l'a dit 2 fois...
Oh oui !
Là, regarde ça !
Tu vois ce que je vois ?
Hé les gars, y a un truc là !
Ils doivent avoir plus chaud que nous.
Hum... y a un iceberg...
Et bah si c'est ce qu'il faut faire pour avoir plus chaud,
compte pas sur moi pour le faire avec toi.
Oh les gars là, c'est pas un iceberg droit devant là ?
Un iceberg droit devant !
Oui, ben c'est ce que je viens de dire en fait.
Nom de Dieu...
On l'a rasé de près, dis donc.
Rasé ?! Bah oui mais non...
On l'a pas rasé, on l'a carrément percuté là !
Le bruit ? Le bruit, t'as pas entendu ?
Énorme bruit.
Personne m'écoute dans les films.